i want to start by congratulating you on
your emmy nomination you've won
three times yes so you'd think enough
yeah
come on give it up thank you three times
i know crazy huh where do you keep your
where do you keep your emmys well when
you come into my house i have like
shelves and they're up there on the top
and uh it's a beautiful thing you have
to look for them so it's not like you
walk in and go
right you have to look right that's good
because some people are obnoxious about
it no they're you know
right there yeah they're like glued to
their door when you enter right and you
walk in and they take you and say look
over here yeah
well you have an emmy yeah they have
lights that shine down on it
right right if i had one i'd keep it on
the floor by the front door so when you
walked in you knock it over
oh i'm sorry yeah gosh
uh so uh do you still get okay you've
won three times
you're nominated this year do you still
get excited going to the emmys and be
honest
no i don't and this is doesn't mean i
don't want people to vote for me please
do
but um do you know how you see people
accept those awards and they're always
like
oh my god oh my god and you really think
that
it it changes your life in some way and
it really doesn't
no it's just it's kind of it was i
thought there was something wrong with
me in fact i think i was on
this very show where i said i keep
waiting for it to wash over me i was on
a hit show
and and i got an emmy and not that i'm
sad about it or anything but it's just
really there's equanimity around it and
i remember you said to me that's very
healthy
emotionally healthy so thank you for
that yeah yeah no i i if anybody knows
about emotional health
yeah it's this guy right here this man
right here yeah i'm the most emotionally
healthy guy in this town
um no i i do believe that i do think
it's uh that
people you know it's so interesting when
you go to the uh emmys or any award show
in this town basically and and what
happens is there'll be five people up
for something
and one of them wins and then four don't
and the four who don't
are millionaires right live in amazing
homes and get to do
a dream job for a living but you see
them and they're like
why why jane lynch and not
me well i've often said it's
like people in show business actors
especially it's like we're rejection
junkies
like you go through you're sensitive
about rejection so you get in the
business
that's mostly rejection rejection fight
through it to get to a point where you
like you make a living doing it and like
well let's have a special festival of
rejection
where like only one out of ten gets to
feel good
very unnatural it's very it's it's
dark and it's evil and it's sinister
yeah yeah i think but yeah
but i won three times we're really
getting the word out on the emmys
it's a sinister organization of
evil-doers yes are you i mean are you
usually asleep when the emmys are on
yeah well i go to bed at like seven
o'clock at night seven o'clock
i'm usually far are you ill no no i just
who goes to bed at seven
jane marie lynch i love i love ending
the day and going up to my room and i
have a couple of dogs
the youtubes in my ear and then i fall
asleep with my mouth a gap
for after about an hour and then i wake
up at like 11 o'clock
wide awake i go downstairs and get some
dark chocolate with peanut butter i eat
that and go back to bed and i'm up at
like five
wow and i don't like getting up when
it's dark i like when the sun comes up
but
how do you go to sleep i mean most
places in the country especially la at
seven o'clock it's like
it's yes it's light out it still is i
mean the sun is pouring in through the
winter
it is through my bedroom too yeah it's
like my wife loves to go
eat dinner at like five o'clock
in the afternoon me too and i don't like
to eat dinner
when i could get a sunburn if i sit near
the window
that feels wrong right yeah she's like
well it's just good to go really early
and then we'll eat really quickly and
then we'll be home and it's all out of
the way
that whole eating thing it's like i want
to go out late and wear leather pants
and just check the scenes
yeah i don't get that
i don't get that i'm talking about i'm
on your wife's no i want to wear leather
pants and no
shirt and just and walk and walk into
restaurants and be like that's right
this
is what you're dealing with you're
wearing a plaid tie yeah
yeah that's so oh this is tv cone and
the real conan
wears a slightly more erotic tie
and you're wearing just bashing like an
idiot now thank you you're welcome
you